With their records now digital, can we
infer the underlying clinical processes
that patients receive as they traverse
the complex service areas of a hospital?
More importantly, can we identify
differences in these processes and
the impact these have on outcomes and
costs?
This analysis is common
in other industries and
is referred to as process mining.
However, these industries typically have
mechanized processes, where automated
sensors routinely and accurately
provide digital timestamped data.
This is not yet the case in health care,
which is still a largely manual industry
and one where care steps may
be documented digitally but
either incompletely,
inaccurately, or after the fact.
Nevertheless there are situations where
process mining appears to be feasible.
This is research from the Netherlands,
where process mining
originated in the late 1990s.
It examined the care of ischemic stroke
patients, patients with a clot in
the arteries of their brain,
in two hospitals shown here.
The results clearly indicate
significant differences,
with one hospital on the left here
emphasizing the use of treatments
aimed at protecting brain cells to
limit the damage from the ischemia.
This is the more state
of the art approach.
This is early work, but here at
Georgia Tech we feel that process mining
is a potentially
important technology for
re-engineering a health
care delivery system.
To make it safer,
more cost effective, and ultimately,
a more valuable and
responsible component of our society.
Which of these are limitations of
the Dutch ischemic stroke study?
Check all that apply.